a virus can have more powerful
consequences than any terrorist action
and if the world doesn't want to wake up
and consider this enemy virus as public
enemy number one I don't think we will
learn from our lessons it's been
impossible to avoid the headlines just
under 2,000 new cases the GP surgery in
Brighton has been closed some people
call it the super spreader but how bad
could this current virus really get it's
a very very tense atmosphere right now
halfway through quarantine and I am awed
and how worried should we be it's near
us about so we need to worry about it it
is absolutely critical that public
health authorities recognize a super
spreading event before it goes
absolutely exclusive
[Music]
we've all heard of this coronavirus by
now
whether you're worried or not it's here
it's in the UK and in dozens of
countries around the world covet 19
that's its official name has killed more
than 1,000 people and infected tens of
thousands but I wanted to get behind the
science the numbers and noise and to
work out what we need to do to protect
ourselves and ask just how concerned we
should all be does it worry you at all
so then just grab your Kela joy street
performer you're on the streets pretty
much every day how do people feel about
coronavirus scary but to me I don't
think he's around here I'm not worried
at all are you worried I'm not gonna
sneeze I feel like it's kind of perfect
saturated NHS will deal with the
and they will go good well you don't
know when you might contract it and you
know what can happen to you like if they
were dangerous I mean what doesn't kill
me makes you stronger
it's milk you know a lot of people not
just the elderly the young people to
first stop in trying to answer that
question asking someone who's been
covering the story since it broke are
you worried about Quinn advice I'm not
worried about me personally contracting
coronavirus because I just don't think
I'm going to be in contact with someone
caring coronavirus they're calling this
the 21st century virus it's a runway
virus you're just one plane ride tube
ride train ride away from having this
spread and spread and spread so it's
interesting to watch and my personally
worried no not yet
let's see how it develops so how did we
get here
the co bid 19 coronavirus emerges the
city of Wuhan in China in December 2019
experts think the outbreak started here
in the Hunan seafood market it used to
be a bustling marketplace now it looks
almost like a ghost town inside the
market it wasn't just seafood to sell
live animals were sold next to newly
slaughtered ones sparking concerns that
the virus might have been transmitted
from animals to humans many of the first
cases of the deadly virus either worked
or shopped in the market coronaviruses
are a large family of infections at the
mild end they include viruses that cause
the common cold but some of them are
much more serious they are named after
their crown like spikes which you see
onto a microscope they actually
originated in animals and if you make
the jump to humans
it took China a month to isolate and
identify this new strain but once it was
clear what they were dealing with the
authorities responded rapidly
Wuhan and more than a dozen other cities
were locked down restricting the
movement of 56 million people train
stations and airports were deserted in
Beijing large groups of people gathering
in restaurants wear band face masks sold
out and even the lists were shut off in
Hebei province to discourage people from
going outside Ohio even though all of
that happened the virus spread serious
and imminent threat to the British the
patient has tested positive for croon of
start with breaking news on the corona
virus outbreak my new corona virus
infections at the detective Ben another
case I did on our two cases of infection
in the UK as soon as cases of the virus
were confirmed in the UK the government
announced it was a serious and imminent
threat we've had a super spreader
dentists running out of face masks
flights suspended to China school
shutting and even doctors surgeries
closing so whilst we've been out filming
we've heard a news off another GP
surgery closing this one has shut its
door it's literally on a residential
streets and this surgery would usually
be busy on an afternoon like this but
what we're seeing here is a sign on its
door urging patients to contact a triple
one for advice should they suspect they
have coronavirus I mean your house is
literally opposite the surgery that's
now being shut how do you feel it been
like a couple of doors down
it's quite other than making me think
now the speed the virus spreads is one
reason that why we should all be worried
each person with the disease on average
could infect 2.6 other people the main
danger from it is that it spreads quite
easily but actually the mortality rates
from this coronavirus are estimated to
be about 1% so what actually happens
when you have Co vid 19 well you get a
fever a dry cough feel short of breath
in severe cases you could get pneumonia
breathing problems and eventually organ
failure and death
this corona virus is a respiratory virus
and it appears to be spread through
droplets so when people cough and sneeze
and other people would then breathe that
in or have contact in their eyes then
they could become infected that way
another way that people can become
infected is if people coughing sneeze
into their hand and then touch the
surface and then somebody else touches
that surface afterwards doesn't wash
their hand and perhaps eat something or
touches their mouth nose or eyes but
even if you are exposed to this corona
virus you don't necessarily need to
worry
this corona virus isn't particularly
dangerous so in terms of the severity of
disease it can cause the illness is not
terribly severe and most people will
experience a relatively mild illness
have you changed the way you do your
day-to-day life oh good because it'll
content so what is it that's in the back
of your head that makes you worry we
will be so when you're on the bus and if
somebody coughs next to you do you why
it's just much more your head you guys
honey look I have made the flu two weeks
ago I was probably the pastor people
concerned about being in a lecture
theatre win so is there a cure here's
what will actually stop the virus
quarantine is the only way containment
and that's why the government so keen to
stress stay at home wash your hands you
know just follow basic hygiene rules the
worst thing you can do is to suspect
you've got corona virus and go out into
the general public they have
laboratories they're all racing to find
a vaccine across the world they really
find the best they can
that vaccine wouldn't be available to
use for this outbreak but it would
protect us from future outbreaks
[Music]
we've then proceeded to check those
guests reported her vid 19 has caused
chaos for those caught up in quarantine
when you go outside you have to wear
your mask and you are supposed to keep
your distance
there are thermometer guns everywhere
people are upping their their personal
hygiene we are allowed to do anything
inside offense but not allowed to go
outside the real hero for me on the ship
is the pastry chef he's determined death
by chocolate is preferable to the virus
so today back out into the big wide
world it's not a sense of fear has such
obviously there is still a little bit of
concern albeit very minimal that people
might have or show negativity towards
you might try and avoid you if they can
now one thing that should reassure us is
that this isn't the first time that a
virus like this has spread far from it
the most infamous corona virus is SARS
or severe acute respiratory syndrome an
outbreak of that strain it spread a
global panic killing one in ten people
who were affected in the South's
outbreak I I was in Hong Kong and I sat
next to somebody who had court SARS and
I had to be self quarantined and during
that time I was a bit anxious obviously
well I chaired the Hong Kong government
SARS inquiry and what we did is we
looked back at what lessons could be
learnt but in general I think if we
follow a sensible precautions it's the
message to everybody here's the official
guidance on how to protect yourself and
others from getting the disease wash
your hands obvious but washing your
hands frequently with soap and water or
hand sanitizer will remove viruses and
bacteria you pick up if you haven't had
a chance to wash them then don't touch
your eyes nose or mouth don't cough or
sneeze into your hands make sure you use
a tissue keep your distance from people
who are unwell at least one meter
between yourself and other people
especially those who are coughing
sneezing and have a
Biba and take care with animals or
animal products when visiting markets
the thing that makes cro mid-nineteen
stand out compared to other
coronaviruses is this social media it's
insane the things you'll find online the
World Health Organization is calling
this a massive info Demick they've even
partnered up with social media platforms
to make sure their information surfaces
at the top of people's feeds and to try
and stop a misinformation spreading look
they're on Instagram Facebook Twitter
tip-top YouTube you name it they're
there but there's a dark side to all of
this social media has also allowed a lot
of people to spread the racist slurs and
means and even famous footballers have
fed into it we've been talking to a lot
of people Reni told us that they've seen
examples of racism against Chinese
people have you had any personal
experiences yes we have like had a few
like here and
in Madrid as well I just people coming
up the SLA old coronavirus watch out you
know warning danger that kind of thing
we kind of just like rush it off
yeah it's kind of new to us to be like
stigmatize we are a bit worried just
even coffee really so you in public
yeah and you're worried about coffee
really you trying to hide it a little
bit really yeah yeah yeah you know you
don't set up a panic on there Landesman
outbreak people being always resis about
people I don't know if I'd goes by a
saying racist I think I just say is you
are definitely more cautious about going
to university and for the sake of the
fact that you know that like what 40% of
the student body are from China because
that pair is coming from dick it has
become like oh do you have the Barrows
which can generate from and we've heard
stories about people you know from
Chinese people saying they've
experienced prejudice and racism yes and
people see them in the street and they
coffin and they start running away and
stuff I mean how do you feel about that
does it worry you in any in any case
that when you go on the buses trains
the only weapon we have against the
virus is trying to slow how quickly it
is spreading limiting movement of people
and quarantine indoors with symptoms is
our best offense when people think about
pandemics they're thinking doomsday
scenario you know zombies on the street
arms and limbs falling off people dying
and dropping dead it won't be light up
even in the short time we've been making
this beast the corona virus has moved on
storms he has canceled gigs the China
Grand Prix has been called off there's
even a mask shortage in the UK whatever
happens next
this story isn't going away
you